hope you had a great New Year's Eve I
don't know if I did
which means I did yes
now I'm not an optimist or a pessimist
or even a gynecologist despite what it
says on my business cards but I always
see my glass half full especially while
I'm waiting for the pill to dissolve in
my drink
because that's what America is and I
believe we have a lot of room for
optimism because like a pervert with an
iPhone at the bottom of an escalator
things can only look up
[Laughter]
because after all right now everything
is down in the dumps we're talking lower
than Don lemon's ratings or Nancy
Pelosi's neckline
the economy crime how can this stuff get
any worse
oh yeah kill me's on today
talk about getting off on a good foot
huh
but we do have reason to think
positively for a whole bunch of things
you've heard of the slippery slope and I
don't mean the ramp that slides UPS
delivery man into my basement
slippery slope is when stuff keeps
getting worse by virtue of it already
being bad well I believe 2023 is the
year when the slope hits the wall and
that's because stuff just went too far
we let the nuts take the driver's seat
and it's time for the pendulum to swing
back to some form of normalcy the adults
need to take charge and not ones in
diapers
here here are my predictions which are
basically hopes first we'll start
treating crime like crime again for so
long we let far left radicals Define
crime as a response to Injustice like
the unfairness of having to pay for
deodorant instead of stealing it from
CVS
or the inequity of some people not
wanted to be stabbed how dare they
yet over time social injustice and
poverty decreased but crime still does
it like kill Mead's next book it only
gets worse
how do you know there is one yes that's
true fact is they're radical theories
were as corrupt as their radical
Solutions but now it has to get better
because it can't get any worse and what
about biology once again we've let the
slippery slope turn into a 90 degree
Cliff where genitals reality so bent you
think it has perroni's disease
with men happily calling themselves
women and other men who used to be women
claiming to give birth while other women
claim to have penises and not the ones
belonging to their husbands that they
keep in their purses
[Laughter]
for a while there we sat back and we
were really polite figuring we didn't
want to hurt the feelings of crazy
people in public but now that the insane
has taken over not just the asylums but
School boards and hospitals and
pediatric associations I think parents
have had enough and they're speaking up
and speaking out and the nuts who
identify as something else are being
seen for what they truly are nuts
it's not about drag queen Story Hour
it's about genital mutilation redefined
as gender affirmation hopefully parents
in general will start taking their kids
education more seriously seriously
enough to beat the left-wing unions into
Retreat and send their green-haired
teachers babbling on Tick Tock back to
where they belong a therapist office
other non-science seems to be hitting a
wall too covet hysteria is being driven
out by good old-fashioned American
attitude we canceled our lives closed
our businesses and hunkered down at our
homes while the big shots went on
vacation or ate masculus and fancy
restaurants but we're done here and it's
time to move on it's time to get masks
out of schools and send them back to
where they belong at orgies for rich
people
finally it seems that cancel culture is
on the ropes and it's this show and it's
this audience that made that happen sure
the weasels will still come after us
howling from their social media purchase
desperately trying to reinvigorate the
Mob all the while paying Elon eight
bucks a month
but we got him where we want them Now's
the Time to send them grabbing their
bags like they're Sam Brinton at the
Southwest carousel
I'm not gonna lie I miss him yeah
and his shiny head
this is the year to do it so either
you're with me or against me and frankly
I don't know which one I'd like more
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guess he's on our
first show of the year so we can get it
out of the way
opposed to one nation and co-host of fox
and friends Ryan please kill me
he's open for more a-listers than Stormy
Daniels
actor writer and comedian Jamie lissow I
thought that was funny
[Applause]
she's written more speeches than Joe
Biden stolen former deputy National
Security adviser KT McFarland
and finally she's like January cold dark
and arrives with a giant credit card
bill Fox News contributor
cap
Brian I have a two-prong question for
you the first prong is your resolution
going to be to spend even less time with
your family right so and the second
prong is are you as optimistic as I am
about 2023. you can answer the prongs in
any order you like second yes can I
consult yeah yeah no Jamie should I go
first
yes okay
second prop yes
I love the optimism I can't believe it's
you yeah you are not an optimistic eye
by Nature did the prompter tell you what
to do or do you tell the prompter what
to do that's the bigger story I think
this is true cancel culture is coming to
a close we're out of people to cancel
we're beginning to get off the mat we're
beginning to take uh to take action but
guys like Jimmy Kimmel and others still
going after people Yeah by spending most
of his teams and 20s in blackface right
so I find it unbelievable I think most
people are looking into their closet and
going I better shut up now because I
can't live in the world I created so
that's my second problem the first prong
again Jamie do you remember the first
resolution resolution TV more or less
spend less time with the family that
so-called family that we've never seen
less and it was by their request yeah
when I come in they're like there's no
showing home so soon it's on Saturday
there's a reason for Daddy being always
on TV so Jamie um do you know that we
changed years in Alaska or is there a
time lag uh we we change years we're
what we're five total years behind okay
right now
are you as optimistic as I am are you
cautiously optimistic I'm cautiously
optimistic because I feel like we've
been optimistic before and maybe got you
know things didn't turn out exactly the
way we wanted them to but I think this
is the year I really do don't you kind
of think it's the year and look at I
mean Biden Administration by the way
loves New Year's Eve I heard when they
counted down when they got to zero they
were like interest rates haven't gone up
at all this year and they were like
there's been no murders this year and
the binder was like I have in my pants
once this oh man it was a good run
but I had a good I had a good New Year's
I um I'm not allowed to drink I don't
know if you know that yeah but it's
always like a uh I used to beat bat like
if you're guys ever been so drunk you're
lying on your back looking at cloud
formations like trying to figure out
what they look like or whatever and then
you realize you're inside and your house
is on fire
[Laughter]
I was like that one looks just like a
fireman
[Laughter]
but I really am optimistic though I
really it's going to be a good you know
it could be the year that you meet that
special someone Jamie it could be I just
gotta raise the funds
[Laughter]
in theories it can't get worse but I
think it gets worse it gets worse oh
yeah and what ways well the economy
guess we're so we have inflation we're
going to have an absolute crisis with
China at some point in the year the
southern border is is we've now turned
it over to drug cartels this is why we
have Americans for my monologue
no no no this is I'm glad you brought
this up I had China and and
my monologue I said no it doesn't work
I'll just get rid of it right and then
you come on here and you throw it back
in my face absolutely ran on your parade
no I think it gets worse but then I
think ultimately it gets better you have
to go through the fire in order to you
have to have a burning platform before
the American people say okay I've had
enough he thought they had enough at the
election in this pastor like but they
obviously didn't and so I think we get
it gets worse there's we have a real
recession and we have inflation and we
have you know the homeless thing is bad
the drug thing is bad the China thing is
bad who knows so maybe we have a bigger
war with Russia and then I think the
American people say okay I've had enough
this is over could it be our culture has
changed so much that we are so separated
that a lot of the things you mentioned
don't affect a lot of people like
homelessness only the people in the
cities are talking about right so it's
and then we're indoor people don't pay
attention they're uh you know they don't
even know that China owns Tick Tock you
know that's right but if you're in the
in the flyover states you're dealing
with fentanyl yeah and you're in the
States where people are leaving this
that's not a city problem as much as
it's a rural problem so I think the
problems are all over I just don't think
it's bad enough to force you you are a
sunshiny rainbow yeah well no but then
thank God you're all dressed in black
you're the Grim Reaper
[Laughter]
wait a bit before the show could you
kill kill Mead
for your girlfriend
[Laughter]
are you optimist
IC no why not yeah I always you know you
pretend to be pessimistic but well I
don't know I think something bad is
going to happen I still think we know
what it's going to be yet because I'm
not good with optimism or like High
Hopes So to avoid needless needlessly
worrying what I do is just like remind
myself how many of the traumatic things
in my life were also complete surprises
right right like don't worry it's going
to be okay more like don't worry you
will never see it coming yeah you don't
the things that keep you up at night are
never the things no you you always worry
for nothing but then you don't worry
when you shut off yeah exactly yeah so
some real bad is going to happen none of
us we cannot even imagine we don't know
yet so we shouldn't worry about it yeah
thank you for that Jamie think about
that I've been so worried about
everything
what's going on but I think no I think
it's I've got a positive message at
least yeah it indulge my positive
message
well I'm still sitting here yes
how was your how was your uh New Year's
Eve it was fun I went to Julie
bandhurst's wow wasn't invited to that
either yeah well I can understand you
being not invited but I have a hit show
you know type two hit shows I should
have been invited twice so you you
forget that I have the radio show Fox
and Friends for a really successful
member Saturday night but I don't want
to slow you down yeah yeah
yeah well you know what no one watches
that crap you mean your old slot on
Saturday
I love Brian all right up next Newsom
goes on a bender signing laws for Crime
covet and gender hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else